yes the Bitcoin ETFs are up there in
terms of some of the most popular ETFs
but we still see more flows into Bitcoin
directly generally speaking I think the
ETF is very good for the industry it is
a sign of maturity it's a sign of that
crypto as an asset class can mature
having that layer around part of the
crypto ecosystem I think is a very good
thing for the crypto ecosystem itself as
well all right guys bang bang uh I
thought a great place to start this
conversation would be around the changes
in investing Trends right uh public.com
is a very large business today uh you've
got a huge user base the way they act
today is very different than maybe
investors were acting five years ago
what are some of those trends that
you're seeing that have really allowed
you to build such a big business yeah I
think what you've seen in the in like
the last call it five years is that
realt investors have really gone through
a lot of different Market cycles and
because people are really learning by
doing they had a lot of learning
experience it usually take maybe a
decade or a few decades to really go
through right but if we really look back
we launch in September of 2019 to be
precise and at that point in time you
had you know two something percent
interest rates you know markets were
doing its thing and then literally you
know what is it you know five months
later you had the co drop and the
circuit breaker hits in the stock market
multiple times within the day something
that hasn't happened in call it 100
years or so right and um and so uh that
obviously was like one massive kind of
learning moment and obviously that drove
you know a lot of retail into the market
they saw it as like an opportunity to
kind of you know buy the bottom which a
lot of them did as we've seen in our in
our numbers and then obviously
throughout covid right stock market was
the only Arena that was open Sports were
off uh people wanted to have have some
teams to be rallying behind those became
you know stocks and companies that drove
a lot of uh volume of of course and just
there people being loan at home and
stuff um and then suddenly you know you
have interest rate changes happening and
like each of these Cycles has I think
asset classes attached to them and if
you look throughout Co you had your Co
stocks right you had you know your you
know travel speculation you had work
from home theme you know uh Health Care
things like that then suddenly you know
in
2022 um you know you went into a you
went into
um into a market where you know people
were suddenly looking at you know crypto
rallies and things like that I train one
mean sorry um and then 2022 you know
things were kind of like rejiggering
people were flying back to things that
felt more value again and that all
happened within like three years you
know interest rates started to rise
again and suddenly things like bonds
became interesting right like us
treasuries like the six months tble was
the number one investment on the app
last year for us like the number one
asset you know which is something that
was unheard of because Bonds were pretty
much you know like non-existent for a
decade plus and so I think seeing all
this happening in such a compressed time
frame was quite unprecedented and so
people that entered the markets before
like 2019 and then went through all that
learning period have really changed
their behavior literally on an annual
basis and and that's what we've seen
like we've seen people that started out
on like a chiino coin and now put you
know serious money into us treasuries
which is like to extreme ends of the
spectrum right so now what do you think
is driving that change right it's very
fascinating if somebody could buy kind
of the the meme coin and then they can
go buy us treasuries did they get
smarter did they learn you know kind of
more knowledge about the Legacy
Financial world did they understand what
they were doing when they were buying
the meme coin it was just like you know
loose monetary policy and meme coins go
up or or what was really
happening I think again people learn by
doing and I think people um learned uh
uh you know by seeing what's happening
as they as they are involved often say
that investing is a forcing function for
financial literacy where if you have
skin in the game you will care as you
care you will automatically be more
attentive and educate yourself and read
the news more properly and things like
that and so I think people being
invested I think is just generally a
very good thing for society as a whole
because people people are just get more
involved in things they might have not
been involved in otherwise because they
have skill in the game and um and I
think what happened within crypto
specifically was crypto was the first
asset class that was born retail so the
first people that got rich on crypto
were regular people it was not the big
hedge fund managers or anything was
regular people and that is a story that
is obviously something that is a pretty
attractive story to people and so and
then the other end you had to think a
lot of a lot like a lot of crypto have
was just a lot of community that was
built around it because of that and so
you know people are look like people
want to be part of something the same
reason why you support a sports team and
go to the game and hang out with your
friends to have something to talk about
I think that same happens in communities
around anything else and you know that
anything else can also be a
cryptocurrency for example and I think
that's what you've seen with also
especially these like community-driven
coins like you know Sheba and Dodge and
whatnot where people know pretty well
that there's you know no underlying
function none of that really than the
thing itself you know kind of like a
piece of art to be honest you know and
um uh and so from that point on I think
you know people like that brought people
into the markets and then as they
entered the markets that's when they
started to educate themselves around you
know how does yield really work you know
what are the market structures you know
when something goes up why does it go up
you know um etc etc and then that brings
them into other asset classes like
stocks and then that brings them into
other CL classes like you know bonds and
treasures suddenly and so on but I think
the question is like what pulls him into
the market in the first place and but
it's an initiating kind of driver and I
think what you've seen in specifically
2020 2021 was that crypto was for many
people at initiating drive there was the
entry into the markets as a whole not
just the crypto markets so how do you
think about something like the Bitcoin
ETF which you know some people would
argue is going to pull interest away
from the actual cryptocurrencies
themselves and now people can just go
buy this stock that gives you exposure
to bitcoin and and maybe it's the
industry itself is maturing a little bit
and kind of becoming more sophisticated
as well but do you expect Capital flows
to change or no the people who would use
public uh or kind of some of these other
brokerages like they are very much they
want to own the coins they want to have
direct exposure and the Bitcoin ETF is
more for like Wall Street
investors yeah and this is exactly what
we're seeing like what we've seen so far
is that yes the Bitcoin ETFs are up
there in terms of some of the most
popular ETFs you know as like so far at
least and and um but we still see more
flows into the into Bitcoin directly
into the actual Bitcoin cryptocurrency
and it's interesting I don't know if I
can like describe exactly the thinking
there maybe it's just also people
getting kind of into it and maybe they
just want to add to positions that are
already there and things like that
because there's an obvious price
difference between going directly into
the cryptocurrency versus you know uh
investing into the ETF um like guess you
know be honest ETF is much cheaper um
but uh what we've seen so far is really
different Behavior there generally
speaking I think the ETF is very good
for the industry and to your point I
think it is a sign of maturity it's a
sign of that you know crypto as an asset
class can mature you know and so on and
you know when I talked about this the
other day I kind of you know got a few
comments of like oh you know something
like the government regulating crypto
like that kind of goes against it I
personally think you know there's a few
things I think there's a difference
between crypto the asset class and you
know blockchain the call it like you
know a ledger as a function for
potentially being used as a financial
system in some regards and those two are
just very separate things and you know
one's a technology we can use for many
things we might want to build but the
other one you know like the coin itself
can be an S Class by itself and the ETF
just kind of carves out that function of
it and puts it into more markets and
makes it more accessible to more you
know people and Brokers and all that
kind of stuff and so for that aspect
right I would say it's very very good
that there's also something that is that
has a little of oversight that is more
regulated because I personally think
that you know like the the the financial
markets have matured over you know 100
plus years in the world and you know
humans a lot of learnings and you know
it can be easily like I think it's too
simple to just be very binary and be
like regulation is good or bad depends
on what the regulation is and there's a
lot of things that's you know I think
are are baked into the financial markets
that are quite good to also protect
investors and so on and um having that
layer around part of the crypto
ecosystem I think is a very good thing
for the crypto ecosystem itself as well
what's fascinating in talking with you
is already in just a few minutes we've
talked about ETFs we've talked about
meme coins we've talked about treasuries
we talked about value investing we've
talked about Bitcoin Etc right like you
all have this like Bird's eyee View and
now it seems like the product that
you've built has become the multi-asset
platform where people can do everything
from options to crypto to traditional
Stock Investing to bonds Etc talk a
little bit about maybe the philosophy of
like what is the product ultimately that
you're trying to build and like how do
you measure success this episode is
brought to you by bet online do you like
making a profit from sports betting well
set yourself up to take home the most
profit possible using crypto to fund
your sports betting casino and poker
account at
betonline.ag you can avoid costly
transaction fees get your payouts
lightning fast and do do it all securely
and anonymously with the highest deposit
and withdrawal limits in the industry if
you want to get in on the action do it
the smart way with crypto at bet
online.ag head to the website sign up
with promo code pomp 100 to get 100%
bonus on your crypto deposit today if
you go and you deposit they'll give you
100% bonus if you use promo code pomp
100 bet online the game starts here
betonline.ag go check them out today
yeah and so how we think about
internally is from our business goal
perspective we want to be people's
primary account and then for the user I
think that means is that we very much
believe that if you can manage all your
assets in one place you will end up
likely making better investing decisions
because you can move money around
different asset classes and different
investing strategies uh within the same
place and that holistic view that you
can have yourself over your assets and
your money um will you know will just
make it easier for you to have you know
a better understanding of it and you
know potentially make smarter decisions
for yourself and you know that falls
into things like that we've done a lot
of work to build we call internally the
holding system it's like basically like
the tech layer that sits on top of
everything there like a real-time you
know Ledger basically which enables you
know realtime money movements between
all these asset classes and that means
you know I can you know sell like I can
sell a US T right now and move that
money directly into a cryptocurrency a
few seconds later and like that type of
you know uh uh technology sort to say
like the the ability to move money
around between different asset classes
and that kind of speed and so on um and
just having that kind of you know direct
overview of everything um I think can be
just very powerful for people's you know
performal management of better wording
but just like how they manage their
money in general when you see kind of
this management idea Legacy investors uh
the you know wealth transfer that's
supposedly coming that everyone keeps
talking about for for the last decade um
they had financial advisors they had you
know I give it to someone else and I
kind of like forget about it to a degree
maybe I meet with them twice a year uh
but that person they've got it they're
going to figure it out uh they're going
to go allocate 6040 you know Global
portfolio and and really kind of go with
the academic Theory or the people are
using public talking to a financial
adviser is that kind of getting kicked
out of the industry or or are you kind
of a workaround how do you look at the
technology versus maybe the human side
or the advisor side of a business like
this yeah
yeah I think the Spectrum was
historically always thought about just
as either it's as like either it's it's
it's active or passive and passive often
meaning it's being managed in theory if
you have your money into like in an ETF
it's managed within that fund right so
there's a big part of it's already you
know sort of say the way we think about
it is that it's just it's not that
binary it's way more nuance and that
spectrum is much wider and so internally
we even talk about things like there's
guided investing there's automated
investing before things before something
is even managed right and in that world
I think you know folks are not either or
you know you want to have the ability to
you know do a speculative options trade
one day potentially even just because
you think it's fun or whatever you know
and at the same time you want to have
you know money in uh you know the NASDAQ
ETF and just let it sit and you know
compound over decades and I think that
Duality exists for most people really
and um the other side of it I think is
also I think a lot of people and that's
what we're seeing obviously because
we're also an active platform you know
as a default but is that people do want
to have some control over it themselves
and that doesn't mean that part of the
portfolio might not like uh uh could be
managed you know back to even an ETF
technically is managed in some regards
um but it just means that you know
people like the sense of that they have
control and um I think the this notion
of you completely give it to someone to
manage and just like don't look at it
and move away I think it's going to go
away more and more especially also
because what we've seen specifically
throughout the last few years is that
you know Financial education through
social media and whatnot has so damn
accelerated you know like when we
launched like we launched T bus on the
app um you know q1 last year and when we
when we launched it we jumped on with
reporters talk about it like we had you
know really deep financial markets
reporters that we had to explain how
does the table work again you know like
because it was so you know these are
like Professionals in the space and just
because it was so you know just like
Irrelevant for such a long time you know
within the public Community you suddenly
like it took a week and you had people
talking about building uh uh building
ladders for for the bonds you know
basically you know meaning you know you
build like a bond ladder so you you know
kind of get cash flow through a certain
period of time as maturity in like
different maturity links and stuff like
that and like that you know it went from
like people borderline have not really
thought about or heard about or
understood how these things work to
people talking deep strategies within
like a week and I think that type of
like rapid education in these like
bite-sized formats is just what exists
today which didn't really exist 20 years
ago and so that generation didn't go
through that and I think that just makes
people also much more Comfort
comfortable and confident that yeah they
could potentially run power portfolio
themselves you guys recently launched
options and one of the interesting Parts
is that you're going to give 50% of the
options Revenue back to the user
obviously this gets into payment for
order flow uh a lot of different
platforms kind of how they think about
their relationship to the user versus
maybe other constituents that they work
with why are you giving 50% of your
Revenue back to the user and like how
exactly does that work yeah so you might
remember that um in 2021 we actually
stopped participating in payment for
auto flow on the equities trading side
like in the regular stock uh uh trading
and we did that for a few reasons number
one um you know uh it's it leads to
Better Price execution for the user and
just creates you know just like more
transparency for people to know that
like if you execute a train in public
you know public will do its best to make
sure it executes at the best price and
the other piece of it is that P for aut
generally you know it incentivizes a
company like us for that you know we
want people suddenly to trade a lot etc
etc and it kind of creates this like
misaligned incentives between The
Brokerage and the customer and you know
that impacts things of how you think
about product development and what
features you do and you know things like
life cycle Marketing in the app and all
that kind of stuff and it you know and
so like just thinking of that like your
your business model impacts your
incentives which impacts how you design
things and um when we launch options
which was one of the most requested
features we had kind of ever right um
the thing was we looked at again those
Market structures and we were like okay
in the market structures in options you
actually cannot get rid of the market
maker as long as you don't necessarily
become one yourself which is obviously
quite a process to do that but you
cannot get rid of them right and so
payment for orderflow because market
makers are so baked into that market
structure you can't really get rid of it
now we were like so what is a more
transparent way to align our incentives
with ones of our users and kind of
continue that thinking throughout also
in the like you know also in the in the
in the options markets and that was a
sense of like okay what if we actually
give part of the paylow revenue that you
make on options trading and give it back
to the user because it creates this
transparency for them to really
understand exactly how much money do we
make uh on each trade that you're making
because you're making the same amount
you know exactly how much we're making
so cre some transparency therefore
understanding like like and having
Clarity of like what our incentives are
as a business in that moment you know
and in options trading we make money on
that and so therefore it's like yeah
someone who trades more we will make
more money on that but it's better for
the user to understand and know that you
know and have Clarity there and
transparency than not and um and then
generally speaking you know that just
adds a little bit transparency just like
the market structures as a whole right
the stuff is super complex I literally
just you know scratch the surface here
like we could talk about the whole
podcast about those Market structures
there
um but it is you know something that has
been fairly intransparent that is
important I think you know for people to
understand so they understand incentives
so they understand you know how things
work and also if these things change in
the future that they know what that
means for you know their assets for the
future as well when you think about
building the business it's a big
business today right uh I don't know how
many employees Revenue like whatever
numbers you could share that just kind
of give people a sense of like how big
this business is and then maybe we can
get into like the actual company
building operational stuff that you've
done to to get here yeah so we're few
million users um and again we launched
um a little over four years ago so this
is now our 50 year Market officially and
um um and obviously you know how you can
think about it is what you've seen
throughout 20 and
21 was um a lot of user growth a lot of
people went into the markets but also
the behavior was I would say in most
cases a little more speculative and what
you've seen throughout the last you know
two years now roughly right or soon to
be two years um is that that behavior
has changed to be colored you know less
speculative more fundamentals driven etc
etc which also means people are actually
moving way higher dollar amounts into
the markets and so like we've seen for
example our like first deposit of people
that sign up and deposit for the first
time into the app that
20x throughout the last call it 18 20
months um and there you see that just
like the the the behavior has
drastically changed you know of those
people and so on and that's how you kind
how you can kind of think about and so
you know in these markets you see maybe
less people creating new accounts but
the people are coming in are way more uh
um you know kind of like serious about
you know their investing uh as as they
get
started now as you've built the business
um for years millions of users you've
had a hire very quickly uh you've
probably moved offices multiple times
like there's all these things that go
into hyper growth how did you keep the
culture an area where people wanted to
come work here the people who were
working there didn't want to
leave yeah um first I think tenure is a
wrong thing to look at to be quite
honest because um um you know U we have
the board we have Jessica Neil who was
the chief 10 officer at Netflix and you
know I personally love the the Netflix
um you know employee handbook for
example and just like this whole notion
of a company is a sports team not a
family and you know if you take the
sports te analogy right the best player
stay and it's completely fine that you
potentially have players on the team who
you know will do a phenomenal job and
will really fit into what the company is
for a year or two or three and then they
might not and that is completely okay
and so I think tenure is generally the
wrong thing to look at because it's not
necessarily a sign of success right
there maybe certain people that
shouldn't work with you what we rather
look at is the ratio between voluntary
and involuntary churn of your employees
so how many people that you want to be
in your team are actually leaving your
team versus how much are you in control
of who's at the team aka the people that
you let go and generally speaking I
think you know that if you are more in
control of who's on the team aka the
ratio of people that you let go is
actually higher than the people who are
quitting themselves that I think means
you have you know generally speaking a
more healthy culture because culture is
really just how you work in order to
make the company successful you know and
um you know and that's you know those
like pingpong tables and parties and
whatnot um and so you know and so I
think that's that's how we like rather
like just like rather look at that right
um yeah so spots the family how do you
go about evaluating talent both as
they're coming in to work at the
business and then also whether they are
one of the top performers or you may
need to part with them and go find
someone else for the role this episode
is brought to you by frck historically
the wealthy had a hidden secret in
investing they would spend a lot of
money and use very big teams to conduct
tax loss harvesting tax loss harvesting
is the timely selling of Securities at a
loss to offset the amount of capital
gains tax owed from selling the
profitable assets later but now frck is
bringing this incredible advantage to
any investor they'll literally lower
your tax bill regardless of how much
money you have they use state-of-the-art
technology through a product called
direct indexing to allow investors to
invest in the S&P 500 while getting all
the benefits of tax loss harvesting
without the big Bill if you want to
learn more go check them out at fre.com
that's
fc.com I'm a big fan of the product and
I even became an investor in the
business fre.com go check them out today
yeah and I think um our view on that
developed over time like we had this
moment where we raised a ton of money in
2021 we hired a bunch of people um team
grew really damn
quickly and um we reached this time
where we were like okay now let's like
you know bring the experienced manager
who comes from a little bit of a bigger
Tech firm etc etc and then suddenly what
turned out you had also people on the
team who maybe you know rather have
one-on ones with people than you know
actually be deep in the work and what
we've really I think learned for
ourselves which kind of became a little
principle at public now for management
is like at public every manager is also
an IC
and you must have a love and an
obsession for the craft and that falls
into you know mic is really deep in
figma fils with you know the direct IC
designers right like literally yesterday
I was really deep in like you know copy
docks of some life cycle emails that we
sending out and like stuff like that and
I think you know everyone needs to be
really deep in the work and has must
have this like love and Obsession of The
Craft because I think that's really what
everything kind of comes back down to
and I think there's too many of these
like management mindsets of like which
leads to people wanting build armies and
whatnot where they think their worth and
the value to the company increases with
you know the more budget they oversee
the more people they oversee and whatnot
versus the actual value they drive for
the company and hiring should be a last
result not the first option it should
not be a strategic move for like we want
to do this let's hire someone to do that
right hiring should be the last result
of like we cannot figure out different
way to do this therefore we now need to
hire and um you know so on so like I
think there's really the sense of that
the biggest thing we care about is
people that are completely willing to
get their hands dirty and you know think
that is like and that's what they get
their joy out of right and so on and I
think that culture just needs like that
needs to be there at all times and I
would say we we had a small moment where
we lost that to be honest um and I think
throughout the last 12 to 18 months
we've been trying to aggressively you
know make sure that that's truly what
every single person he how do you think
about fundraising you've fundraised in
really good times and you've also I'm
sure evaluated doing it in bad times as
well uh how has that changed and maybe
what are some of the lessons that you've
learned there always raise more money
than you think you need because you
don't know what's going to happen um
that's for sure like when we raised like
the last time we raised was in 2021 was
February 2021 so we're still running on
that money today
and at that point in time we raised $220
million which was nuts just let's be
honest eing bonkas right we were 40
people 45 people when we did that you
know and also at the time with very
little Revenue like we were in the
middle of GameStop there a lot of
momentum behind us right but we were 18
like less than like 15 months in market
like super young product super small
team and we raised a ton of money on
that and at the time like I remember the
first term sheet was for $100 million
and then we just like talked what and we
were
like should we make it 200 because seems
like we can and to be honest it was one
of the best best best decisions we've
done um because our future would have
looked very different if you would have
raised half of that right and in that
moment that money was just ridiculous
100 was just ridiculous so 200 was just
stupid you know and um but it was one of
the best decisions to be honest because
we're still running on that money today
and it was you know uh like we could
have predicted the future of how the
Market's going to contract and whatnot I
think generally speaking what's
happening right now is very healthy uh I
think what happens in the zero interest
rates you know environments is that you
know Yan and I had this term we talked
about of like the uh the Zer like the Z
Zur so someone who you know in a Zer
environment becomes becomes an
entrepreneur because it's easy and that
is all washed out which ALS means you
just have more Talent density you know
and I think in these markets people get
focused again on like what are we doing
here we're here to try to build a really
healthy good business that ends up
making money that is the number one
purpose of a business um not all the
other distracting things around it and I
think you know in those Zer markets I
think we also all like as an industry as
a whole and everyone got very distracted
to suddenly care about a bunch of things
that maybe we shouldn't have cared about
as much and you know that fects company
cultures that affects you know how you
think about money that affects how
people build teams and whatnot and you
know I honestly you know I entered the
the workforce in like before 08 right
and I moved to the US in 2008 and then
suddenly you know I was you know the
person in the job where around me
everyone got fired and then you had 10
years plus where a bunch of people
entered the job market they did not have
that experience and so I think having
this moment right now is very very
healthy for people perceptions of what's
the purpose of the business truly you
know what un economics actually should
look like etc etc and um you know that
obviously means that valuations contract
in the moment in time but they will
expand well at some point again you know
maybe not as crazy as 2021 multiples but
you know prices go up prices go down and
you know we raised a lot of money in
2021 that a very healthy evaluation at
the time you know and we'll raise money
again at some point likely and when we
do we'll see what the valuations at that
point and that is totally okay right if
anyone the stock market knows everything
goes up and down and it's better to be
realistic on that than you know yeah you
know try to get to crazy yeah you said
that the business would be very
different today if you had raised half
or less than what you did raise what
would be different like what where do
you think the business would be I think
it's two things right I think um um
first
off um there's obviously company
strategy would have been slight
different in terms of how you deploy the
capital because if you have less you
deploy likely also a little less um so
that's I think one thing um at least in
the in the like in the you know like the
the like 20 21 years now though on the
other end it would have me it would have
still meant we would have likely needed
to raise money by now that would have
been my assumption and you know that
meant we would have needed to raise
money likely exactly at the time where
valuations would be crazy compressed and
um you know and also and then in that
moment I think you know you still have a
business that runs the way it was run in
2021 early 2022 you know and how
startups at random Venture Capital will
operated at the time AKA you know likely
less efficient than people operate right
now um and it's definitely true for us
like we're now running way more
efficient than we've done in those years
right and
um and then you would have raed need to
raise money at a time where you know
everyone's Minds already adjusted to the
new market conditions but you didn't
actually have time for your business to
adjust prly to that yet or to at least
show the track record that you have you
know and then you have to raise time the
money at a time whether valuations
contract so that combination I think is
deadly right the combination of looking
at how you run your business still being
in the old world the new world having
adjusted and valuations contracted I
think that kills companies and so very
very very lucky that we were in that
position how do you think about uh
regulation obviously you are in a highly
regulated uh industry um there seems to
be a lot of maybe gray area questions
concerns at the things that are like the
furthest out crypto uh maybe even
royalties like these areas that are not
really the mainstream Financial assets
uh have a lot more regulatory questions
than obviously a public stock on you
know the New York Stock Exchange so how
do you think about you know navigating
that while also trying to innovate
generally speaking I think there's a lot
of Regulation still behind right if you
think of you know things that you know
that you have to be accredited and how
to become to and how you can become
accredited in order to invest in for
example private companies you know and
things like that I think that is still
outdated it needs to change to be quite
honest um on the other hand you had some
Innovation right so you know it's now
five years ago reg plus was introduced
which is basically an ability to turn
any type of asset into registered
tradable security and that has been used
to you know turn things like a piece of
art or you know royalties and make that
an investable asset class so you can buy
and sell shares in right so we acquired
a company a few years ago called Odus um
which basically use reg class to do that
and integrating that into the app where
you know now on public you know there is
even you can put you know you can buy a
share in a bank SE or you can buy a
share in the Shrek music royalties so
anyone who watches you know Shrek movie
you suddenly actually make cash flow on
that right and actually the yield on
that when we ipoed that was higher than
most the most you know bonds out there
and stuff and it's completely
uncorrelated to the financial markets
because it's you know based on content
consumption you know not the financial
markets and so and then the ability to
add it to your portfolio etc etc and so
like reg a plus for example thing was a
good Innovation that actually came out
the regulatory environment to enable
these types of things so
you know expensive to to do it etc etc
like as a company but generally I think
we we we had some Innovation this good
as well the Bitcoin BTF is another one
right good that that happened um but I
think there's still a lot that needs to
happen generally speaking like our name
is obviously public and so we often
think about it this way of like it's on
us to constitute like like it's on us to
Define what constitutes a public market
and you know things like making music
royalties actually tradable and
accessible to anyone to participate in
that as a CL
you know um uh is obviously you know
kind of cool and a good Innovation I
would say and I think you will see much
more of that to have this like
securitization of every of everything
happen um but it will take still likely
a decade Plus for you know that to
triggle into more asset classes or into
allet classes my last question for you
is uh it is your job to understand where
you've been where you are today but also
where this entire industry is going what
are maybe one or two things that you
think are going to happen in the future
that either people aren't thinking
enough about or maybe things that
everyone believes will happen and you're
like ah I'm not so convinced that that's
actually going to be where the world
goes um first I think interest rates are
going to stay higher longer than people
expect right now um that's a little
macro take here but um yeah I mean
generally speaking again like number one
it's the it's the securitization of
everything I think you're going to see
um more liquid markets around private
Securities happen at some point I know
kada just had to now close it down I
think it was actually bad for the
industry that you know they were kind of
forced to do that you know despite the
maybe questionable tactics that
potentially were unveiled there but
nevertheless I think it was actually bad
for you know the private markets that
kada suddenly closed down their efforts
to try to build you know like an
exchange for private Securities I think
that was kind of a stupid outcome for
everyone to be honest um but I think
that you know uh uh those are I think
some of the you know more um um you know
exciting things the other one sorry to
be that but like AI I think is going to
have a massive impact right like we
launched Alpha on the app which like a
research assistant which we basically
you know which just like basically like
like an llm that we um trained with
earnings call data and analyst reports
and you know just like historical
fundamental data etc etc so now you can
just swipe down on any stock and ask any
question about the stock and it's
phenomenal how well that thing works and
I think the next step there is obviously
for those tools to be personalized to
our portfolios doesn't necessarily mean
that an AI will like trade for you um or
you know if that's good or bad but um
but just the sense of that you know
what's like the impact that that AI can
have on just like portfolio management
and giving you insights quickly around
your folio I think it's going to be
awesome awesome awesome to see where can
we send people to find you online or if
they want to check out public get an
account where can we send them yeah go
to public.com to sign up and um
obviously you can find me on Twitter at
live Leif Thunder there's a whole other
story to that handle we can talk about
that next
time all right sounds good we'll
definitely do this again in the
future cool awesome thanks for having me